the reality-warping nature of crisis on
Infinite Earths brings up loads of
questions about not only the arrowverse
but the wells beyond the CW series some
of these questions may be answered in
the coming months but sir may never be
answered at all the first three paths of
crisis brings some incredible cameos but
the one that lit the internet on fire
was saved for part 4 Ezra Miller who
appears as a flash in 2017 s Justice
League comes face to face with Grant
Gustin CW version of the character as
the latter is traveling to the Speed
Force neither of them have any idea of
how the meeting is possible and the
movie flash in particular seems
completely oblivious though the pair get
a somewhat awkward moment appreciating
each other's costumes as the TV flash
says this shouldn't be able to happen at
this point the multiverse has been
annihilated by the antimatter wave so if
the DC EU films are meant to take place
in the same multiverse as the arrowverse
the movie flash should be wiped out
along with the rest of that Earth's
heroes one possible explanation is that
time in the Speed Force doesn't work the
same way as it does on earth we've
already seen this as the case in
previous seasons of the flash so as
confusing as it may seem it could be the
movie flash enter the Speed Force before
the multiverses death and the force has
strange relationship with time is
allowing him to meet the TV flash after
the end of all things one of the coolest
things about crisis on Infinite Earths
it's a reprisal of Brandon Ralph and the
role of Superman in earlier chapters of
crisis he plays the Superman of earth 96
who is largely based in the 1996
miniseries Kingdom Come Ralph earth 96
Superman has earned some gray hairs and
his costume insignia incorporates the
color black something uncommon for the
character outside of Kingdom Come he's
killed by Lex Luthor at the end of
crisis part 3 but by the end of the
events we learn the restoration of the
multiverse has resurrected the hero
drawing the resolution of crisis part 5
we see snapshots of other corners of the
multiverse including earth 96 we find a
smiling Superman flying in orbit over
the earth interestingly his costume has
changed the black of his trademark
insignia has been replaced with yellow
and overall his costume looks much more
like the one Ralph wore in 2006
Superman Returns we don't know if the
change is a conscious choice on
Superman's parts or a result of the
changes in the multiverse one
possibility is that it's meant to
signify the character is found some
piece when he's asked about the black in
the costume earlier in crisis he says it
symbolizes at this Hope even in the
darkest of times perhaps this version of
the Man of Steel no longer finds himself
in the darkest of times and decided to
let it show Oliver Queen tides a second
time at the end of crisis part 4 and
this one might just stick with the
powers of the specter Queen's eyes
battling the anti-monitor
and helping to restore the multiverse
his sacrifice is lamented by all the
heroes in part 5 and the presidents of
the United States calls for a moment of
silence and honor of his deeds even if
we accept this is finally the end of a
character who has already died and come
back multiple times in the history of
the I reverse were left with a question
of what's happened to Spectre we don't
know a lot about the arrow versus
version of The Spectre it's introduced
in crisis part 3 when James Corrigan
approaches Oliver Queen in purgatory
about shouting as a spirits new host and
by par 4
Oliver has assumed his new role in the
comics the spectre is a physical
embodiment of the wrath of God and one
of the most powerful superheroes of DC
if the spectre of the CW is similar to
that of the comics the death of Oliver
Queen would likely not mean the death of
the spectre but instead the spirit would
need a new host so did the spectre find
one did it go back to James Corrigan or
is it possible Oliver isn't dead and
will continue to act as a Spectre in the
shadows crisis part 3 introduces us to
Ryan Choi the paragon of humanity he's
one of the only Paragons to be
introduced in crisis at least as far as
the arrow verse is concerned but DC
Comics readers are more familiar with
the name
Choi famously replaces Ray Palmer as a
shrinking hero atom in the your new
Assam comic series while choice solo
series didn't last he remained a hero in
the DC Universe
most recently being recruited into an
eccentric Justice League of America
lineup that included the reformed
villain killer frost and the alien
bounty hunter
Lobo his appearance naturally had fans
wondering if he'd be joining the super
powered clarify the end of crisis but
par-5 concludes without joy obtaining
any shrinking powers or a suit of armor
similar to ray Palmer's this definitely
any question again why I'm here but that
doesn't mean Troy couldn't play a larger
role in the our vs. future and possibly
at another version of the atom as soon
as we meets him in Christ says he makes
it clear he's familiar with Ray Palmer's
scientific breakthroughs and it's Troy
who comes up with the idea of making a
device that will neutralize the
anti-monitor by making him shrink
infinitely whether or not this is a sign
of things to come
only time will tell crisis part 5 enter
the multiverse restored but not exactly
as it used to be the various heroes of
the different CW our verse series
existed on a few separate earths before
crisis and they now share the same world
earth Prime and it's normal to see us
together
Oh normally you'd also have green arrow
and a legend or two but what about the
rest of the multiverse we don't revisit
earth 89 where we see Roberts will
reprise the role of intrepid Batman
hunting reporter Alexander Knox we don't
get another visit with a Robin of Earth
66 and we don't see the fate of Earth
167 for the events of Smallville take
place it's likely we won't see most of
those worlds again in the arrowverse
series and really that's okay what could
have an impact on the arrowverse going
forward are some of the alternate
Earth's we visited before crisis for
example there's effects whether CW
heroes put a dent in the Nazi ruling
faction in the 2017 crossover crisis on
Earth X and made it easier for the raid
to go back home and take them out for
good or what's about earth 90 which was
destroyed as part of the 2018 crossover
l's Wells was a Barry Allen of the 90s
flash show resurrected as part of the
multiverse restoration in crisis part 3
Constantin Diggle and Mia traveled to
earth 666 that's part of their quest to
resurrect Oliver Queen there we meet
some Alice's Lucifer Morningstar from
the series Lucifer from there back and
forth it's clear Lucifer and Constantine
have had dealings before and in
particular
Lucifer says something which has had
fans of the arrowverse and Lucifer
scratching their heads okay I'm only
doing this because I owe you for maze
maze or mazikeen is a regular character
on Lucifer played by Leslie and Brant
she's a demon who used to be the most
feared torturer in all of Hell by the
end of Part 5 we get no indication of
exactly what Constantine did for Mays
and Lucifer not even Lucifer's
showrunners Joe Henderson and LD mode
ravaged
know what the former monarch of hell was
talking about they told E W that line
was as much a surprise to them as it was
to the fans if the issue is ever to be
addressed on Lucifer it will have to be
in its upcoming fifth and final season
otherwise Lucifer and or Mays will have
to make one more visit to the arrowverse
our fans will be left to wonder early
and par-5 of crisis we learn one of the
biggest changes in the restored
multiverse is that only Supergirl and
the other power guns remember Lex Luthor
as being the villain we all know he yes
when Supergirl first awakens in the new
earth Prime she's late to cover legs
being awarded the Nobel Peace Prize and
we soon learn he's somehow the head of
the de Oh even close allies of Supergirl
like her sister Alex look up two legs
are some kind of benevolent
philanthropist he's the best guy know
what the most likely answer to how this
came to be is that it was by Lexus
design just before Oliver Queen's
confrontation with the anti-monitor and
the formation of the new multiverse Lex
reminds you gather Paragons he still has
a piece of the book of destiny
richard previously used to kill the
Superman of Earth 96 and take his place
with the remaining pieces of the book of
destiny coupled with his own intellect
Lex may have figured a way to
consciously will himself into a new role
on earth Prime
this is what being a hero feels like
interesting regardless of how he did it
Jon Cryer's been a hit in his portrayal
of one of DCs chief villains and it's
good to know crisis is unlikely to be
the end of his time as Lex Luthor toward
the end of part 5 Lois Lane drops a
bombshell
and Tyler hoechlin Superman seems just
as surprised as the rest of us
Lois call Superman as he's flying
through the clouds and tells him he
needs to get to Metropolis saying simply
it's the boys Superman dives towards the
earth presumably on his way home but we
never get to see these boys for
ourselves the last time we left them
Superman and Lois had one child of
Jonathan the newborn lends some
much-needed humor to exposition scenes
with the monitor as he keeps
interrupting the aliens portents of doom
with us crying but somehow the
restoration of the multiverse has given
Lois and Clark at least one more son
this is a departure not only from the
pre-crisis CW but from the comics
Jonathan is a son of Lois and Clark in
the comics though he's a teenage
Superboy and a member of the Legion of
super-heroes you know and I used two
pictures together
we were always living on earth and we
had two kids it's an interesting twist
that shorter calls to pair complications
down the road will likely learn who
these sons are how many there are and
whether they've inherited any of their
father's abilities either in future
episodes of Supergirl or in their own
upcoming series Superman and Lois in
crisis parts ooh the heroes encounter
the earlier version of a cowboy antihero
they've had dealings with in the past
Jonah Hex played by Jonathan Schack
they're confronted by hex in a mine on
earth 18 where they're looking for a
Lazarus Pit to resurrect Oliver Queen
Sara Lance and Mia fight and overpower
hex who as of yet doesn't have his
trademark scar when Jonah was trained by
Sara refuses to yield and give them
permission to be in the mine
Sara says yes you are going to get this
scar eventually and cuts into his face
with a knife in the comics hexes scar
comes from a fire and it doesn't look
like an injury that a knife would cause
all on its own if this is actually meant
to be the event that marks Jonah Hex for
good the fact that the multiverse
essentially gets a big reboots might
undo it
hex doesn't appear at all after part two
of the event so as of yet we have no
idea whether or not he still has Sarah
to thank for his good looks in crisis
part 2 about woman and Supergirl
travelled to earth 99 but they believe
they can find the paragon of courage
that world's version of Batman instead
they find an old broken Bruce Wayne
who's content to let his world and the
rest of the multiverse die we learn at
some point this version of Batman
crossed the line and killed one of his
enemies after which killing eventually
became his default he even killed the
world's version of Superman battle not
with monsters lest you become a monster
but we never learned what it was that
pushed about man over the edge we get a
few dog details but they all seem to
have happened after he went rogue he
mentions a bat woman of Earth 99 died
but this looks likely to have happened
after Batman went bad because Bruce seis
escaped first became bat woman because
she thought she could succeed where I
failed implying he'd already been
corrupted before she even became a hero
his final battle with Superman would be
an unlikely source considering he would
have already gone down a much darker
road in order to become Superman's
target if we absolutely had to guess
then it seems a good bet it was a joker
who finally drove the Dark Knight to
cross the impossible line we know that
clown has brought of
virgins of Batman closer that bring
before still the Bruce Wayne of Earth 99
dies without ever mentioning specifics
so we'll probably never know for sure
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the valve so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]